[Music]
hello everyone Perry back here with
another exclusive Collider interview
from Park City we are at the supper
suite thanks to the fine folks at Kia
and right now we have the opportunity to
talk to the cast of the killing of two
lovers I told some of you before I saw
the movie you guys are incredible in
this this is like one heck of a
performance showcase was gonna make
Robert do this he's gonna join us
shortly the director but whoever wants
to jump in a lot of people out there do
not know what this movie is just yet so
who wants to do a brief synopsis I don't
know how much of a synopsis we want to
give right it's story right there's Amba
that's kind of what we've been going
with it's just a zombie flick but no it
did say it's quite self-contained peace
you know it's about a husband and wife
that are going through a separation they
have four children which are clearly
affected and it's it's David's character
I play he's just trying to cope with
this separation Oh looky here come on
down you look great you look great do
you want to you want to jump in with a
with a brief synopsis I think you're
finding a marriage and transition you
know a period of growth and for me it's
in the writing process of it was you
know what happens when people are
growing in a direction and the risk is
the growing apart and this is your first
feature as a solo director so why why
now and why would this story someone who
is logistical both Rodrigo and I teach
and we so we needed to shoot this thing
in the winter in December and it didn't
allow our schedules didn't allow for
both of us to work together the other
aspect was I was just so curious to -
we'd been so connected I was like what
what sorry would we tell a little bit
different if we didn't tell each other
together does he have any specific
specialties that when you were on your
own you're like oh you know like I
needed to hone my skills and in that
category a little more
yeah yeah for sure he's really really
comfortable making actors do it over and
over and over and over and over again
which is why I didn't want him on set
and then just kind of just like getting
you know directly at an idea that he has
a lot of times I am really open to
seeing what the actors are doing and
then the collaborative process not as a
bad thing I think we we've worked really
well together in the past but for me
that was a little it was a little more
nerve-wracking because you have a
partner that you go like I'm scared like
is this going well and they go yes it's
going well yeah can you tell me a little
bit about how the whole cast came
together did any of you know each other
before jumping into this Chris and I had
worked together on the job I was on
previously and just had a wonderful kind
of connection and relationship and I
just thought he was a great actor
it's funny he did a scene and the
director comes into the end of the room
is like if he could do it this way and
it was a very typical television kind of
note and Chris just did it and I looked
at Mosley it was so much better the
other way just so you know he's like
yeah whatever okay and then I called
Libyan joonie who cast me and rectified
who are incredible and I said look here
these children because Rob and I have
kind of been morning to work together
for 10 years right so this has been this
building of kind of we've been a team
somewhat and and I called Libyan I said
hey here are the children's faces this
is what they look like I need a female
actress that can kind of hold her own
with us and sepi was the first tape I
watched and I think we watched maybe 20
seconds yeah she was like it was like
this weird audition drinking wine or
something I was like just picked up that
glass in that phone I was like boom
that's it I don't know if you've said
anything yet I was like we're gonna and
this should just so happened to be at my
management company which made it quite
easy wait so what do you remember what
you auditioned with God do you remember
work she's it's cabaret
I can't remember any excuse I can have
to drink wine during in every audition
so so much of what I took from the film
comes through your shooting style and
what you guys bring so naturally through
your chemistry onset I'm curious what
was not on the page when you first read
the script that when you saw the
finished product you're like wow like
look what or maybe even something that
you felt onset all of a sudden well it's
not that I don't I don't feel like it's
what wasn't on the page because it's
implicit right whenever you write these
complex characters and storylines with
such a rich backstories you get to kind
of fill it in and we all collaborated
together with Robert and filling it in
and yeah it kind of flew off the page it
wasn't that it wasn't on the page it was
just he gave us so much room to
interpret and more often than not our
interpretations really lined up with his
vision and that's it sorry it's just
such a testament to the writing yeah
like yeah it's like that scene in true
romance between Dennis Hopper and
Christopher Walken what everybody thinks
that's improv and really that's verbatim
how it was written this movie is that so
many scenes that you guys give that
exact impression and this he wrote every
word yeah he wrote it and again because
of these beautiful long takes it allows
us to gain momentum and it just the
scene it's so difficult to start and
stop isn't it and and Robert again the
writing was beautiful the second we read
it with like there's no question we've
got to gonna make this immediately and
and again once he put us in this safe
place in this tiny little town of cannot
shoot all magic just started to happen
on-screen isn't it more difficult to
start and stop or have the pressure of
doing such a long moment in a single
shot I don't think it's the at least for
me and these guys to I would I feel and
why I feel like we connected immediately
was because it didn't feel like a
pressure it felt like an excitement and
adrenaline that you just ride because
when there's no opportunity to stop
there's no it's like life you know and
so it really felt like living
in the scene and it you don't start and
stop in real life you can't go back and
oh I want this angle it's like you just
keep going
the other thing actors like old hot rods
right you got to get warmed up you got
to get them going I think that's what we
all love stage and we continue to go
back to it because you have that freedom
which you just it's like having you know
a Ferrari in downtown LA you're just
hitting stop signs and just the motor
never gets more necessarily and I feel
that the work is somewhat lost Robert
did you always know that you wanted to
shoot this movie that way or did you
ever consider a more traditional form of
coverage and editing know when Oscar and
I started talking about this film I I
teach photography and we started having
discussions about could each composition
be a photograph and then the action and
the movement exists within that
photograph so that was always our
initial when we chose to set stuff up it
was thinking about it from a
compositional standpoint of photography
which is a little bit differently almost
we almost argued to do four by five as
well because because I shoot four by
five in in aspect ratio and the only
time we ever chose to kind of move or
you know to where a cut would end up
being would be logistical reasons you
know it's like we don't have a giant
crane to slowly push in and move around
so we're that budget we should have been
able to get that crown what about when
it comes to focus also especially when
you have one-on-one conversations and
characters in a foreground background
went because I found that you were
focusing on characters that you know
very unique time so you feel that out on
set or is all that meticulously planned
before you start rolling no it was
really a live like a live feed or
performance which I would kind of like
to do I mean kind of went on the climax
scenes Oscar where I'm in a golf cart
Oscar's right next to me
and I'm I'm slowly pulling us in and the
focus Bowl is just off on a way and it's
like I'm noting to her who to hit and we
did that kind of throughout the focus
for would be next to me and I'd be
whispering air okay this person now this
person she had set the marks so that we
could kind of experience it for me I was
like they're performing I would like the
camera to be performing as well
very very effective and impressive I
just wanted to add one thing in that car
scene where he chooses to use the
coverage between davidandnicky is so
unique and so telling like it's so it's
such a great way to get into the way
that they see each other is by when the
other person's talking you know it's
actually focusing on the person who's
not talking and that's you you do that
same thing with the focus and I just I'm
such a fan of that it's searching I've
got to take advantage of this
opportunity too because I haven't had a
chance to talk about this yet just in
terms of like composition or the
photographic value of the movie the
moment when we were filming when I
realized how capable hands that I was in
where we're standing there and he's
looking through this little book lid of
his and I'm like what is that and it's
all these pin drawings and he's like oh
it's the storyboard and he hands it to
me and it was frame by frame the entire
movie that he drew himself he was
unbelievable I was like oh you know the
future like you know where you know
everything that we're gonna do I feel
like you you could see the value of that
just in the still you chose for your
official Sundance page it's just like
such a stunning image that really
captures more of the story than I think
people will realize having not seen it I
do really want to ask about working with
your young ensemble here across the
board
incredible what was it like working with
them and how did they adjust to the
shooting style also well they've worked
with Robert on all of your films haven't
they it's just about yeah so they're
pros and these kids just show up to set
and they rate the snack the craft
service table which is you know a table
about this size with Twizzlers on it and
and then they just come out and Robert
just kind of a whisper in their ear tell
them what to do and these kids are
incredible they're so and I know I said
were a term that gets thrown around but
they were truly in the moment at all
time like bug the baby Jonah which is
always when we're in the production
house just a child and I was so
impressed with these kids how did you
meet them they're mine
credible my wife made him nice to buy
and supported her did they did they come
to kind of love this process and love
filmmaking through you or they had done
so Jonah had done a but a feature that
made it hard rego called when she runs
in 2018 and he was three at the time and
they've always been my kids have been in
little things and he was like I want to
be in something else I don't remember
being in that you know and they kept
kind of pressing me so I made the minors
a short last year that that was at
Sundance because they won Best Director
well because they wanted to do another
movie they were like we want to do
something so when I when I was writing
this film I was like they have to be in
it because what they do is they work
their beats out together who's gonna say
what and how it's gonna set a Jonah
obviously at the time couldn't read so
he's like he's learning from Ari who's
so Ari normally reads the script with
kind of aggressively so he knows what
everything is who reads it and finds out
where the kind of key points are and
then Jonah just just like tell me what
I'm supposed to say and when I supposed
to say and then he'll hit it and then I
didn't know until we were shooting this
the scene that was we didn't have a lot
of time to shoot it with David in the
car driving his kids I and I had seen
them off we were doing something else I
walked over and they were talking about
it and they were worried and I was like
oh my gosh you guys are like prepping
for this thing which is really really
cool to see from a dad point of view I
was like oh my gosh you guys are very
serious about what you're doing so happy
love like family coming together who
plays my father is his dad in a film
robert has only made movies with his
friends and family up until now and he's
able to get these incredible forms maybe
that's the way to do it and then build
you know right it's like you don't want
to work with somebody who's acting you
don't know what you don't want to feel
at least for me and for us I feel like
we're all kind of cut from the same
cloth and like we're like animals when
we get out we like we want to play we
want to be surprised we want to Harold
Gus can a great acting teacher talks
about exploding the moment and that's
what it feels like not when were working
together sure but having the kids that
just don't even think
twice and really just you know leap into
this imaginative world they'll do
anything and they're so unpredictable
and I think that's just delicious
I think they grounded us at times guys
thank you so much for your time today
again huge congratulations on the movie
the killing of two lovers do keep an eye
out for it and other big thanks to the
fine folks at Kia for making all this
happen at the supper suite in Park City
like and share this video before you
leave and stay tuned we're going to more
conversations from Park City for you
real soon thank you